all right guys not to steal anything
from uh youtube media here but uh all
credit goes to him for me my idea to
make this video i'm going to attempt to
make my own icon in um powerpoint
um and i'll probably use it as my avatar
from now on because mine's just a
picture of me playing golf so let me go
ahead and maximize this
um
i'm just going from the top of my head i
don't remember exactly what he said but
i know i'm supposed to delete these
what i'm going to do is insert a shape
uh here's a shape
and here's a
relatively
good looking
shape
all right oh that was oh i don't know i
know
all right
we're gonna insert an oval and hold down
shift in order to make it a perfect
circle so go ahead and
mine's gonna be big because i'm cool
all right
um right click it and go to format shape
and this is where i will create my
um
raw created so i'm going to hit gradient
fill and i'll drag this off to the side
so you can see it better
first of all
good gradient fill it just looks cool
like that you can change whatever angle
just just gives it a certain appearance
that's cool
um
that's just for phil and let's go ahead
and choose a color
my favorite that's not pretty though
let's see what color just gold that's
that's fine with me no it's not
now i'm in line color i don't know three
to do something
with a shadow before all right well
we're going to add i'm going to add a
shadow make it pop out and make the size
of it a little bigger that's huge
that's a decent sized shadow blurred a
lot because that that makes it look like
a shadow
how many frames am i getting all right
it's acceptable um
so now we're going to
i want to put a text box on it right
this will
you know it'll be my initials say mkb
right so
well
i'm gonna hit close
i'm gonna insert a text box
just
there
and i'm gonna type
mkb very very simple right it's like
i'm going to format that
right click it and format
so now we're in the text box and we want
it to be
let's just leave it horizontal
leave it in the middle
right now
and
it has to be bigger as we know so let's
change the font
uh i think word art has something to do
with this if i find
like a little design with um
i can do word art
where can i do word or here we go
yeah
that'll stand out right there we go so
let's delete this
cut
and drag this to the middle
of course the font is not big enough for
us
so we're going to make it
humongous
no that's not big enough
it's not quite big enough to fit our
circle
so we're going to shrink that down a bit
and save that
that's a pretty cool image right there
that's going to be my
i guess my avatar if i can figure out
how to do that
so i'm going to save it
first
actually give me a second i'm going to
come back to you and try to figure out
how i'm going to save this as a png or a
bitmap so i'll be right back
all right i'm back and here's how
i'm going to add a backing to this um to
the actual uh circle so i'm going to
insert another shape and this one's
going to be a rectangle
and i'm going to just drag it down to a
good size looks good to me
and i'm going to
format
and send it to the back so that this
shape is in the back and this shape is
in the front
center everything make sure nothing
looks bad
so here is the entire icon it's not
perfect but it's amateurish
uh my fill color it'll be cool to have
it a little
well that's a little dull isn't it
how about this
nope that was cool this one
that's decent but it's not dark enough
so shape fill
make it a little darker
now that's that's monotonous shape fill
will be a
shade of
green
because that's
just
cool
also also if you want to format this
shape you can do so just by right
clicking it again and clicking format
shape
um
i'll choose gradient fill again and
i have a lot of preset colors but
uh where's my oh moss all right whatever
line color line color is just basically
this outside color you see here not a
big deal uh it'll be a solid
gradient line whatever
line style make it a little thicker
okay and give it a shadow this is
important to make it stick out for me so
i'm going to give it a
a the same shadow right here it's under
the circle so i'm going to make this one
under the circle as well
under square as well
give it a little more size
a little more blur
and there is my icon i think i'm good
with the 3d format i could change it if
i really wanted to make it stick
you know out vertically
towards uh whoever's doing it but that's
that looks good right now
now to bring this to bring this into
paint we're going to have this selected
and we're going to hit our print screen
button on the keyboard which i just
pressed
hopefully it will work i'm going to open
up
paint
a second there's paint
sorry if the audio is a little bit off
it has a tendency to do that i'm going
to go
to paste my image
there it is
so what i want to do now is i believe i
want to uh to crop this image out this
image needs to be
uh highlighted this one by itself
to do this all i'm going to do is go
image crop
i'm going to drag hopefully
now
i'm going to drag this
crop that right there
then i'm going to
select all
and i'm going to crop that
see if this works
crop it vertically
uh if i can
grab it somehow
sorry i'll come back when i'm done
cropping this
all right i finished cropping my image
so what i'm going to do is edit
um no i'm going to file and save this
image i'm going to do it as my icon in
my pictures
i'm going to exit this out exit this out
i don't need it anymore i'm going to go
to my youtube page
um
so i can set this so i'm going to click
on my name and i'm going to find my
settings
hopefully let's see hold on a second
to do this go
to more
and hit the change button and i'm going
to choose a file from
my
pictures folder
here it is open
and
it's uploading that image so i'll hit
save changes
wait
wait for it
it will save your changes and that is
how
you create that as your image for
youtube subscribe thanks for watching
peace